we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David Pete we have
that voicemail line is open twenty four
hours a day you can call anytime many of
you did in and around the New Year
holiday a lot of people had been
drinking when they called one call
questioned whether I did something to
get Joe Rogan's and Bill burr to talk
about me the other day take a listen to
this one
hi David it's Clark just had a question
this is Clark Cramer did you pay joe
rogan
and comedian bill burr to speak about
you on their podcast uh I'm just
wondering right I just find it hard to
believe that they would mention someone
is irrelevant is you I'm while talking
yeah that's exactly right what I did was
I found people who have a ton of money
and would never normally talk about me
and I offered them an amount of money
that was meaningful enough to get them
to talk to each other about something
they otherwise wouldn't care anything
about that's exactly what I did it's an
amazing thing I was able to do
absolutely incredible on the bonus show
today louis c.k speaking of comedians
louis c.k is sort of in trouble again
and people are now outraged about jokes
he made regarding parkland shooting
survivors and gender identity issues and
we will talk about louis c.k a little
bit we will talk about how for
undocumented immigrants getting a
driver's license could create problems
with ice immigration and customs
enforcement in ways that were maybe
previously not known or only suspected i
guess we could say we will also talk
about filipino president rodrigo duterte
confessing that he sexually assaulted
his families made when he was younger a
very odd unusual and disturbing story
all of
stories and more are on the bonus show
how do you get access to the bonus show
in the new year same way as in the old
year become a member at WWE in pac-man
com become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show and again 106 new
members on January 1 2019 with this just
incredible 2019 membership special that
we are running if you want to get in on
that and you didn't get the email from
us about that special just contact us
using the contact form at david
pakman.com say David I want that 2019
special what's the deal and I will send
you the information you can sign up and
it's going to be an absolutely
incredible thing we're back back for the
new year we will be here we've got now
we don't really have any planned
vacations pad until we both leave for a
month on Monday other than that we're
here for a really long time yeah and a
month-long vacation is well-deserved I
think at this point we won't exactly
announce when it's going to be we're
just gonna let the audience find out on
their own they'll be like wait wasn't
there supposed to be content being
produced by this channel like where did
that all go but after we after we come
back we'll let you know what happened
yeah we're kidding by the way we are
kidding I know people get really mad
about vacation time and I've said before
it's really important that staff get
time off so we do sometimes take
vacations but that's not happening this
month don't worry we've got a full solid
month of programs for you glad you're
here I will speak to you on the bonus
show very shortly